Everyone saw the pictures and heard uh,
the moving testimonies
of these women and men hit by the earthquake.
In Morocco,
most of the victims count
among the poorest Moroccans,
because they are not uh.
The Palaces of the Monarchy that were uh.
Struck and uh,
these are not the 5 star hotels,
they are uh,
the houses built of adobe
and villages that are often
hanging on the mountainside.
And they had no chance
to resist this earthquake.
Even in Marrakech,
these are not the richest neighborhoods
which have experienced the most significant destruction.
The Riyadh of Strauss-kahn,
by Bernard Henry Levy or uh,
of they couple,
uh,
are probably still standing.
My houses that have collapsed,
are those of the Medina which were the most dilapidated.
And fate invoked to bondo
the seismic risk and in any case the vulnerability
of his homes had been known for a very long time.
But King Mohamed 6,
who has 1 splendid uh
mansion of one thousand six hundred square meters uh,
on uh the field of March,
at the foot uh of the Eiffel Tower,
is undoubtedly more interested in the evolution of the
of real estate uh Parisian
than to implement a real prevention plan
risks uh,
in his own country.
Done exactly
like the earthquake that struck Turkey in February
uh last and Who did uh.
50,000 dead like the one that hit Haiti in January,
two thousand ten,
makingdeux-cent-cinquante-mille dead.
Well,
uh, uh,
the population is not only a victim
of a natural disaster,
she is also a victim
underdevelopment and misery.
Today,
all heads of state attack with good feelings
and uh.
Offer to uh,
help the Moroccans,
including uh.
Countries uh.
Who are more or less angry with King Mohammed 6.
Well, this state,
the age of beautiful intentions and hypocrisy
without a name,
starting with France.
Oh,
Macron does not want to miss the opportunity to show himself
generous,
but he always refuses to grant uh.
Visas for Moroccans who want to come here,
for example.
And then,
France
being 1 of the great powers that,
historically,
uh.
Hold on uh.
Moroccans in misery,
even if there is 1 little frying on the line
between Macron and Mohamed 6
at the moment,
uh.
Nevertheless,
France has always been an unwavering supporter
to the monarchy
uh.
Moroccan since independence.
And uh.
The great French employers
who has a lot of business in Morocco,
some 1 thousand French companies
uh are in Morocco.
Well uh,
he is perfectly comfortable with repressive politics,
uh.
Against the political opponent,
but also against trade unionists,
against the workers,
uh. Who claim.
In fact,
it suits the French big business community well
who of course wants to
exploit Moroccan workers to the maximum.
Then it is necessary to
take all this around international help
for what it is
of the cinema,
and the example of Haiti and Turkey uh show it.
Between the promises of international aid
and what happens naturally on the field,
1 free kick ago.
The only help from those concerned
that will naturally fit the need uh.
Victims will come from the solidarity of the workers.
This solidarity,
it is spontaneously uh
set up in Morocco through uh.
Family ties,
through associations as well.
And then here,
uh,
it is organized on the initiative
of Moroccan workers
and it's so much the better.
But next to this solidarity,
it is also necessary to lead a political fight.
Because for uh,
think about solid,
that is,
to protect oneself
both natural disasters
but also of exploitation and misery,
well,
we have to build a new society,
1 company in which the workers,
the exploited
can enjoy the riches they create.
To this end,
it will be necessary to unite to all
plans to serve
exclusive of the great,
whether it be the repressive monarchies
or uh the so-called western democracy